the horrifically dystopian squid game is
filled with sneaky clues and easter eggs
that predict the front man's real
identity all the major character deaths
and hint to some theories on what to
expect from a second season yipikai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
i'm revealing over 45 twisted details
you might have missed in squid game
spoilers ahead so take care
although the mysterious front man who
oversees the games remains hidden behind
a mask till late in the series the show
does give us a tantalizing clue early on
to his true identity as policeman jun
ho's missing brother when jun ho visits
his siblings apartment in episode 2 look
carefully and you'll see he's heavily
into art that's crucial because if you
look at the front man you'll see how his
interest in cubism has influenced him
and his surroundings for example look
out for objects fractured into
geometrical angular shapes with convex
or concave surfaces the idea of that
looking cubism was to show objects from
multiple perspectives at the same time
rather than just one
when gyeon sebiak and sonwu make it to
the final round they're served a final
meal which the creator has said is meant
to look like the last supper for gion
though when the stake is revealed the
moment is especially significant because
his daughter was taken to a steakhouse
by her stepfather for her birthday prior
to the games geon had also planned to
treat her to an expensive meal but after
losing his winnings could only afford
something much cheaper so getting a
plate of steak at this point feels
particularly ironic and this might be a
bit of a stretch but some fans have
suspected the stepfather who's also
gions nemesis may be connected in some
way to the games so this stake may hint
at that also notice how the three tables
are set out in a triangular shape and
these are on a large circle filled with
black and white squares so the entire
layout is made up of the three squid
game symbols a circle a triangle and a
square one of the three survivors at
this point in the squid games is son woo
and there's some foreshadowing of this
moment in the second episode when his
mother was talking to him on the phone
and she was interrupted by a customer
asking for three squids some other
hidden squid references and symbols in
the series include the hair clip in the
shape of the squid game logo on the
giant robo doll's head the elevator
entrance to the front man's room also
has intersecting circles triangles and a
square shape the guards are organized
into three types by the squid game
symbols on their masks and the squid
game logo is also highlighted in the
guards hot pink uniform colour in the
show's title one of the brilliant things
about the series is how it manages to
get you invested in lots of characters
even though we know they're going to die
because of the very nature of the game
and many of those deaths are
intriguingly telegraphed early on the
way migno dies as she grabs hold of
doksu leans back and falls through the
glass was foreshadowed back in the tug
of war game when she commented that
leaning back made her feel so much more
powerful doksu also foreshadowed his
death in the second episode when he
jumped off a bridge to escape from his
enemies junhoe's death as he falls into
the sea mirrors how he dumped the squid
game worker's body after stealing his
identity so he could go undercover in
the game ali's heartbreaking death when
he discovers that song woo has cheated
him out of his bag of marbles echoes how
he stole a packet of cash from his boss
who owed him money sabiok dies with her
throat slit by son woo the thing she
threatened to do to the guy who lost the
money she gave him to help get her
family out of north korea and if you
look closely you can also spot a scar
already on her neck another bit of
foreshadowing for her fate and songwoo
kills himself at the end like he almost
did when the police were tracking him
down in the second episode there's a
popular theory about the red and blue
tile game which posits that players who
choose a blue tile go on to become
participants in the game whereas those
who choose a red tile become the
jumpsuit whirring workers the original
inspiration for the salesman's game is
very creepy and based on a korean urban
legend called red tissue blue tissue
which is itself based on a japanese
horror story where a ghost appears to
people using a public bathroom and
offers them red or blue toilet paper
there are many variations of the story
but those who choose red are generally
killed in a gruesome bloody fashion
whereas those choosing blue are
suffocated to death
the giant killer robot in the bone
chilling challenge red light green light
is based on a character who featured in
korean primary school books used to
teach children how to read in the 70s
and 80s and we see that same shocking
contrast between the game's childhood
origins and the brutal adult contest in
the show's brightly coloured sets and
costumes which give the competition a
child-like fairy tale feel or strange
fantasy vibe
a recurring theme in the show is how the
blue danube is played over the
loudspeakers just before each of the
deadly games is about to start
the famous waltz by johann strauss jr
becomes a terrible harbinger of what's
to come and the incongruously
light-hearted nature of the music is
completely at odds with the deception
death and destruction that awaits the
players in every game it even plays
during the final trio's last supper
adding to the horrific nature of the
situation
the blue danube was originally written
to help lift the mood of the austrian
nation in the 1860s after the country
had lost a war was economically
depressed and morale was generally low
and the squid games organisers may be
trying to use this upbeat tune in a
similar way to encourage the players who
are in financial straits to raise their
spirits and keep playing the music's
also used in this amazing shot from
above where the players move along m.c
escher-inspired stairs with their
seemingly endless motion around the
spiral style staircase reminiscent of
the constant dizzying turns on the
viennese walls the trippy look and
disorienting design of the staircases is
also deliberate homage to escher's art
piece relativity in which the usual laws
of gravity don't make sense an analogy
perhaps for the horrific reality of the
squid games when many players announce
they want to abandon ship after the red
light massacre the prize money they'll
end up four fittings announced and as
the cash drops into a massive perspex
piggy bank it's accompanied by the sound
of a chiptune
similar music played drawing the scene
in the first episode where gian tried to
win a present at the arcade for his
daughter's birthday another horrifying
connection between the arcade and the
squid games is that the present gehen
wins for his daughter comes wrapped in a
black box with a bow similar to the
coffins used for disposing of dead
bodies in the squid games
check out the multiple pictures the
front man has in his old apartment of a
dark street at night underneath the
bright blue sunlit sky they're from the
empire of light collection by surrealist
artist renee magritte and inspired this
iconic scene in the exorcist like so
much in the squid games they point to
the unsettling and upsetting contrasts
of the show's world where kids games
have deadly consequences and brothers
who once sacrificed a kidney to save
your life end up shooting you off a
cliff to your death by the way if you're
intrigued by the front man's character
and wanted to know more the show's
creator has said a potential season 2
might explore his story in greater
detail while also including more on the
police the vip episode makes it clear
that there are squid games happening in
other parts of the world the contest in
korea was the best meaning the secret
network that runs a diabolical
enterprise must be relatively extensive
and in the final episode the meeting
that guillen has with his bank manager
reveals a clue that the bank itself or
its manager may also be involved the
hint is in how the bank employee
mentions they have a vip only service
for wealthy individuals like gyun the
term vip here seems specific and could
suggest guillen is being offered the
opportunity to become an observer at the
game should he wish after all illness
mentioned on his deathbed that he
started the games with other people who
like him were basically bored despite
being hugely rich the deposit of so much
money into gyan's account would also
under money laundering rules likely
trigger an investigation into the source
of the funds and this doesn't appear to
have happened it's also suspicious that
gen ho's call to the korean police just
before he was killed hasn't resulted in
anything after all the location of his
call could have been easily traced by
his boss it could simply be police
incompetence however it could also
suggest there are higher ups in his
police department who've been paid off
by the squid games not to investigate
the yearly disappearance of hundreds of
people
a twisted detail that was deliberately
hidden from players is that from the
start all six games to be played were
depicted on the walls of the dorm area
in the beginning these were obscured by
the player's bunk beds and although
knowing what the games would be would
have given everyone much better odds of
survival it's only as more and more
players are killed off that the true
nature of each game is revealed i think
the added meaning here is that despite
all the front man's claims that the
games affair the truth is intentionally
hidden from participants and only
revealed to the few who make it to the
end another example of the injustice of
those in charge of the system is when
ali goes to claim his unpaid wages and
finds his boss playing a computer game
rather than trying to fix his business
so he can pay his workers just like the
vip is in charge of the squid games
ali's boss is only interested in his own
entertainment at the expense of others
so did you spot any other interesting
details or easter eggs in squid game and
what do you think was the most
horrifying or heartbreaking moment in
the show leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below if you
enjoyed this and a thumbs up and a share
are hugely appreciated you can tap left
for my next netflix video including a
full breakdown of the symbolism monster
and ending of horror series midnight
mass or tap right for something else
you're sure to like thanks for watching
and see you next time yippee kai movie
lovers